ils étaient environ 80 ce soir-là écouté
attentivement les solutions exposées
dans le programme de jean luc mélenchon
pour les quartiers populaires lutte
contre le chômage santé transports ou
encore logement les propositions sont
nombreuses
en préambule la france insoumis souhaite
changer le regard sur ces quartiers
qu'elle estime oubliés des politiques
publiques
donc on considéra que les quartiers
populaires santé un problème on
cherchera à éviter de regarder ce qui
s'y passe
or les quartiers populaires c'est avant
tout une grande richesse ne les fesses
démographique une richesse culturelle
artistique une richesse sportive
économique et même une refaire une
richesse civique puisqu'aujourd'hui la
lutte contre les discriminations elle
s'exerce essentiellement à partir des
classes populaires priorité absolue de
jean-luc mélenchon pour les quartiers
les plus fragiles l'éducation l'ancien
sénateur socialiste veut notamment
réduire les effectifs par classe 25
élèves maximum au lycée il souhaite
aussi recruté 60000 enseignants ou
encore développer massivement
l'enseignement professionnel et
technologique
après quand il ya de l'éducation et
quand il ya une perspective d'une autre
vie qu'une vie essentiellement basée sur
le commerce et sur l'accumulation de
biens dans les banlieues a pas de raison
qu'on se sente plus mal qu'ailleurs dans
son équipe il ya quand même des gens qui
sont qui sont issus de
différents quartiers différents courants
et qui peuvent représenter des choses
qui peuvent répondre à des attentes que
peuvent avoir les gens dans les
quartiers populaires est d'après les
derniers sondages jean luc mélenchon
semble pouvoir accéder au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle
une des clés de son score se trouve
probablement dans le vote des classes
populaires
un vote qui depuis quelques années se
tournent de plus en plus vers marine le
pen